bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le 7-8 loisirs vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence tout de
suite avec le sommaire la saison
artistique du théâtre national commence
demain pour ce premier spectacle
brigitte fontaine revisitera ses
classiques dans une orchestration variée
et originale la vie de saint françois
d'assise sous forme de 28 panneaux
représentant les fresques de giotto un
chef d'oeuvre de la peinture italienne à
découvrir dans l'église saint-pierre du
lac
enfin notre rendez vous dédié aux plus
jeunes il sera question d'éveil à la
comédie au théâtre montansier à
versailles une nouvelle activité au sein
d'un des plus anciens théâtres de france
un rendez vous à noter ce dimanche à
15h30 le château de breteuil se
transformera en décor d' aventure de
cape et d'épée
l'association les lames du slam sur
scène par dont deux menés par le maître
d'armes michel ollivier fera re fit
revivre les moments où les mots les
romans pardon de mousquetaires dans un
spectacle d'escrimé artistique une mise
en scène mêlant intrigues et
rebondissements avec une vingtaine
d'escrimeur ce divertissement est offert
aux visiteurs sans supplément sur le
prix des visites on écoute
henri-françois de breteuil le
propriétaire du château nous en dire
plus sur cet événement on va avoir
carrément un spectacle qui est fondée et
basée sur les trois mousquetaires car il
crée des duels extraordinaire en faisant
revivre d'artagnan les digues ou
d'arrivée athos porthos aramis etc
ils sont vraiment des athlètes
formidable d'ailleurs michel ollivier
lui-même a été champion du monde
d'escrimé artistique je vous le disais
en titre le théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lens ce samedi
sa saison artistique pour ce premier
spectacle c'est brigitte fontaine et la
troupe des musiques à ouïr qui ouvriront
cette saison ils revisiteront le
répertoire déjanté de la reine des kékés
les images de mélanie poquet lors de la
répétition publique du 22 septembre
chanteuse poète comédienne brigitte
fontaine c'est un peu tout cela à la
fois samedi 24 septembre c'est elle qui
ouvrira la saison artistique du théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accompagné par la troupe des musiques à
ouïr elle revisitera son répertoire dans
une orchestration varié et original est
à la fois un orchestre plein de plein de
sonorité riche de sonorités on va dire
dans une forme de multitudes au niveau
des sons puisqu'on joue tous de
plusieurs instruments
donc on se retrouve dans une belle
surprise de découvertes sonores et dans
la même découverte sonore on se retrouve
au beau milieu de la poésie de brigitte
fontaine qui est aussi à un délice
incontournable de la chanson française
les plus grands titres de brigitte
fontaine reprendront vie le temps d'une
soirée
un voyage où se mêlent free jazz
musiques orientales et influences plus
contemporaine interprétés les choses ça
veut dire cela revête un petit peu à sa
sauce et puis surtout surtout laisser la
place aux au public de
de faire de faire son histoire est une
chanson de brigitte fontaine c'est un
c'est un univers aussi c'est un bon
moment et j'ai une envie une excitation
oh
2 comme à la radio à la symphonie
pastorale des années 70 à aujourd'hui
le spectacle au brigitte est une
invitation à la folie de la reine des
kékés à noter si vous ne pouvez y
assister ou souhaité revoir ce spectacle
il sera diffusé prochainement sur notre
antenne et on passe maintenant à notre
entretien
ce samedi à 15 heures l'espace albert
camus de maurepas dévoile sa saison
culturelle
pour l'occasion le spectacle mondial
cabaret sera jouée il reprendra les
traditions du cabaret pour un tour du
monde en quatre-vingts gags avec
nuclaire couvreur chargée de
programmation à l'espace albert camus
pour nous parler de cet événement
bonjour clair moins chaud alors pouvez
vous nous présenter ce spectacle le
mondial cabaret qu'est ce que ce sera
oui alors ça va être un spectacle qui
mêle du cirque la magie du cabaret et
qui s'adresse à tous les publics en fait
l'idée s'est présenté un spectacle
d'offrir aux morts passe bien et au
public qui ne connaît pas vraiment
l'espace albert camus un spectacle qui
détend un petit peu tout le monde pour
tous les publics et un petit mot du coup
sûr les deux artistes qui sont team do
you do viennent dit oui alors ce sont
des artistes français qui ont créé ce
spectacle en fait en 2009 à new york et
qui tourne mondialement donc c'est une
tournée mondiale il voyait plusieurs
pays oui alors en fait ils reviennent
juste depuis lundi de d'argentine ils
ont fait une tournée ils sont même
descendus jusqu'à ushuaïa et donc nous
avons la chance de les avoir demain à
l'espace à berchem et donc dans l'île du
cabaret qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve un
petit peu comme des rois des cons midi
musical sur deux shows alors il ya de la
magie à des claquettes
il ya un petit peu il ya beaucoup
d'humour évidemment c'est très décalé
c'est très déjanté et surtout ce qui est
important c'est que ça s'adresse
vraiment à tous les publics pour que les
jeunes enfants les familles et les
personnes un petit peu plus âgés s'y
retrouve
c'est une entrée libre alors soyez une
entrée libre sur réservation il nous
reste encore un petit peu de place c'est
suivi après d'un petit cocktail pour que
l'idée c'est qu'ils aient le maximum de
convivialité à l'espace albert camus ou
alors on le rappelle c'est pour lancer
du coup l'ouverture de saison de cet
espace albert camus qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouvera d'autres comme événement
important dans l'année alors on a
plusieurs spectacles familiaux
l'idée justement la commande politique
était de reprogrammer réaxer la
programmation sur des spectacles
familiaux mais aussi tout public
comme je vous le disais pour que tout le
monde puisse s'y retrouver et du coup
nous avons des spectacles qui s'adresse
à la fois aux adultes est à la fois pour
des familles des jeunes enfants
également
on a des spectacles qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve trois ans pour donner leurs
points par exemple nous avons
au niveau des adultes trois spectacles à
noter à ne pas rater rien de ce père qui
est une comédie 100 % recyclé parce que
tous les tests qui vont être utilisés
sont des grands textes classiques qui
sont recyclés et évidemment tous les
tous les décors les costumes sont
recyclés donc c'est vraiment un grand
moment à vivre en famille c'est à partir
de 10 ans mais ça peut s'adresser aussi
à des adultes après nous avons piano
furioso qui est un récital classique de
musique de piano mais qui en fait est
revisité également parce que c'est
l'histoire de gilles ramade et son
parcours au conservatoire de manière
humoristique
donc ça désacralise aussi la musique
classique pour permettre au plus grand
monde de passer un bon moment en même
temps de la qualité vous axez si voilà
il ya un autre rendez-vous peut-être
pour les plus jeunes pour les plus
jeunes publics
alors pour les plus jeunes publics nous
avons deux dates pour à partir de 4 ans
petit rouge qui est un spectacle très
poétique qui revisite également
l'histoire du petit chaperon rouge dans
des décors de bambou qui sont
magnifiques et l'arbre sans fin qui est
un
une réinterprétation en fête du livre
album jeunesse de claude potier d'accord
donc tous ces rendez vous sont à
retrouver de toute façon sur le site
internet
on peut s'inscrire encore y'a pas alors
oui il reste des places et j'ai oublié
de préciser aussi nous avons quand même
une grande pointure de la musique de la
guitare emmanuel rossfelder qui donne un
récital à l'espace albert camus ça c'est
unique et c'est quoi alors emmanuel
rossfelder que je vous dise pas de
bêtises
c'est le 21 avril le 21 avril amateurs
30 d'accor et bien on note toutes ces
dates
merci beaucoup à tous de nous avoir
parlé de tous et rendez vous à ne pas
manquer surtout pour plus d'information
l'adresse et le numéro s'afficheront en
bas de votre écran
exposition maintenant jusqu'à fin
septembre l'intégralité des fresques de
giotto sont présentés en église
saint-pierre du lac à montigny le
bretonneux sous forme de 28 panneaux
photographiques le visiteur est invité à
découvrir la vie de saint françois
d'assise
un chef d'oeuvre de la peinture
italienne ouvert à tous messagers de la
paix amis des animaux sans françois
d'assise fait partie des saints
catholiques les plus connus pour son 20e
anniversaire l'église saint pierre dulac
consacre une exposition à ce religieux
l'occasion de découvrir sa vie au
travers des fresques de giotto du xiiie
siècle
c'est un homme qui aujourd'hui encore
marc des chrétiens des non-chrétiens par
son message de paix par son message
aussi d'harmonie entre l'homme la nature
la création dans son ensemble c'est un
homme qui a beaucoup fait avancer
l'église vers une plus grande vérité de
l'évangile et c'est pas par hasard si le
pape actuel a décidé de s'appeler
françois c'est à cause de saint françois
c'est parce que comme saint françois il
ne voulait
une église pauvres pour les pauvres 28
reproductions photographiques illustre
les épisodes emblématique des miracles
comme le dialogue avec les oiseaux aux
discussions avec le sultan d'égypte
l'une d'elles évoque la rupture de saint
françois avec son père riche marchand
d'assises pour montrer à quel point il
veut se libérer de tout cet héritage
familial il se met littéralement tenue
sur la place centrale d'assises rendant
ses vêtements à son père pour montrer sa
volonté d'une liberté totale par rapport
aux biens
pour compléter cette présentation
l'église accueillera jusqu'au 25
septembre un manteau authentique ayant
appartenu à saint françois d'assise une
première dans les yvelines pour les
passionnés de véhicules anciens un
rendez vous immanquable ce dimanche à
partir de 14 heures la ferme du manet
accueillera la deuxième édition de
pleins phares sur l'auto le thème cette
année la belle époque
plusieurs dizaines de voitures
défileront dans les rues et seront
exposés le public pourra voter pour sa
voiture préférée des animations pour les
enfants et des adultes seront également
proposées tout au long de l'après midi
marie toussaint chargé de l'événementiel
à montigny le bretonneux nous en dit
plus donc cette année nous avons la
chance d'avoir deux très belles voitures
stylo morgana
il ya beaucoup de morgane dont trois
roues chose d'exceptionnel nous avons
une ds nous avons de très vieilles
voitures mais aussi des voitures en
connais un petit peu stiller 5 206 voilà
on a un panel très large de belles
voitures et deux voitures un tir plus
connu les belles voitures font rêver
effectivement et puis voilà le passé il
existait de très très belles choses en
votre enfant se mêlent peut-être un
molière le théâtre montansier a lancé
mercredi 21 septembre une activité
d'éveil au théâtre et c'est mélanie poca
qui va nous en dire plus bonjour mélanie
bonjour camille alors cette nouvelle
activité proposée dépasse le simple cour
de dire qu'il faut savoir que le théâtre
versailles et est l'un des plus anciens
de france il est même le deuxième plus
ancien après celui de metz
il était inauguré en 1770 par le roi
louis saez et son épouse marie
antoinette
il se situe même à deux pas du château
royal bart pour en revenir à
l'expérience du théâtre
ce terrain est une expérience globale
les équipes de montpensier parle même
d'un chemin initiatique avec un cours
hebdomadaire
bien sûr mais aussi une initiation à la
technique écoutez mes enfants vont
découvrir le théâtre à travers une
visite aussi à travers des rencontres
avec des techniciens costumier
machinistes metteur en scène et vont
également assister à des spectacles de
la saison pour voir en action
à quoi ressemble vraiment le théâtre
alors c4 ce spectacle seront 4 il y a le
médecin volant avec les farces de
molière les contes du chat perché des
célèbres contes de écrit par michel aimé
les rustres est ni d'où ils pourront eux
aussi monter sur scène c'est un peu le
but des ateliers on va dire aussi dans
puisque notamment il ya un cours
hebdomadaire qui a lieu tous les
mercredis après midi il s'agit bien là
de moore
le fruit du travail d'une année les
cours de théâtre sont dispensés par
myriam où les hommes c'est une ancienne
institutrice en ch'ti tutrice
spécialisés et elle est aujourd'hui
actrice et comédienne alors à quelle
tranche d'âge sont destinés ces ateliers
alors ça s'adresse aux enfants de 10 à
12 ans se sont laissés est mêlé sixième
et pour cet éveil ils ont dû prouver
leur envie de participer à travers une
lettre de motivation et marie nicolardot
convient d'écouter nous donne cette fois
les raisons
le théâtre c'est un art vivant donc on
n'y va pas de façon passive et le but
était vraiment de créer une émulation
dès le départ voilà puisqu'il faut être
vraiment partie prenante dans un cours
de théâtre puisque le théâtre mobilisent
évidemment la voix mais aussi le corps
donc pour que les enfants sont impliqués
on s'est dit qu'il fallait dès le début
donné donné un peu la note mais
malheureusement cette initiation est
déjà victime de son succès et oui 12
places étaient disponibles les
inscriptions se sont fait durant le mois
de septembre et lors du premier cours le
21 septembre et s'était déjà 15
mais pas de panique il reste les
ateliers d'arts plastiques lors des
vacances scolaires est aussi assez
sympathique
il ya là un côté après chaque
représentation du mercredi après-midi
toutes les informations se trouvent sur
le site de l'établissement merci
beaucoup mais la ligne de nous avoir
fait découvrir ses ateliers on espère
que ça suscitera peut-être des vocations
théâtrale chez les plus jeunes
et c'est maintenant l'heure de notre
agenda les rendez vous à ne pas manquer
cette semaine
dimanche à magny les hameaux aura lieu
le dernier tournoi de pétanque de la
saison organisé par les amis de la
pétanque l'occasion de participer à cet
événement convivial où tout le monde est
invité à jouer peu importe son niveau
mardi 27 septembre à 20 heures la salle
jacques brel présentera le secret de
fabula un jeune homme ordinaire devra
sauver un monde où les personnages de
livres prennent vie un spectacle musical
mêlant humour et magie pour toute la
famille c'est la fin de cette fuite
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il a très bon week-end
à tous